[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
andrew brandt sports illustrated
columnist and he's a former packer
executive he was there for farv he was
there with aaron rodgers draft um let me
start with that andrew if i said right
now start a franchise
and i'm you have to give him a seven
year contract mahomes justin herbert
josh allen
not where i thought we were going
morning dan morning uh
i'm gonna go with the new new kid on the
block justin herbert
uh do you mean that if i if you're on
the clock right now and all three are
available
and and this has nothing to do with your
roster
just that quarterback
you're taking you know what mahomes is
you sort of know what allen and herbert
are
a smaller sample size
and you're going to invest in herbert or
josh allen before patrick mahomes
yeah
i mean listen you just mentioned farvin
rogers i'm a strong believer that
quarterback is an armed position
now all those guys have cannons all they
do
i'm just thinking this guy's got the
biggest cannon because you can coach all
the other stuff
you can't coach
arm strength
at a high level and
again tiny sample size of the three big
arms there i'm thinking herbert may have
the biggest arm that's where i'm going
well i think josh allen has the biggest
arm but keep in mind
these three guys all had big question
marks coming in we didn't even think
that justin herbert was going to play
that he was going to sit josh allen had
no real success
going into the nfl i mean he played at
wyoming and then patrick mahomes we
thought he was sort of a brett favre of
wannabe and then
here they are you know
maybe the top three quarterbacks
you know dan you just said something
there no one sits
right
no one sits we had aaron rodgers said
three years that that will go down to me
as the longest sitting of the first
round quarterback ever that's why i
think
jordan love will be the quarterback
there next year but listen
mahomes sat a while but no one sits i
mean you say justin herbert i know with
the injection of tyrod taylor but he
wasn't gonna sit and all five rookie
quarterbacks are playing right now
no one sits in him yeah but they should
like i don't think trey lance is ready
to play but they they don't
i know i know i know you know
garoppolo and andy dalton and i'm like
and i i admit it i'm like why
you're like what are you gaining
by having those guys play now i know the
guy's gonna be raw and rookie and make
mistakes and fields and lance but
they're gonna make some mistakes whether
they start now in november december or
2022.
all right let me get to the topic i
wanted to talk to you about because
you've been on fire on twitter so andrew
brandt sports illustrated columnist host
of uh businesses sports podcast former
packers executive and director of
villanova's sports law and business
program
you said in a tweet that gruden was
sacrificed for the greater good and in
parentheses put nfl owners in there
who sacrificed him and why
i don't know that's what i'm trying to
figure out let me explain i just don't
get this
for people who haven't been following
this closely this is an inquiry into the
washington football club toxic workplace
sexual harassment by a law firm hired to
do this
yet
a espn broadcaster from emails 10 years
ago
is the emails that we see that's the
information that comes out of this can't
debate the emails obviously repugnant
reviled gone consequences right but why
this
and why not others and why not more
someone somewhere wanted this out wanted
gruden gone maybe wanted to maury smith
saved last week whatever the reasons
i don't know what the greater interests
are here
but
to me
this is a sacrifice
for something else
not coming out
for diversion to this story rather than
other stories like this continuing toxic
workplace story in washington
i don't know dan i'm i'm
listen
last week
demora smith is having a vote on his
re-election
the day emails come out which are very
damaging to him which are very uh
offensive to him
this week
gruden continues to coach during the
weekend and more drip drip drip of
emails and he's out
what's going on here and i guess my
question is will the drip drip drip
continue beyond
john gruden
okay if i'm the commissioner and this
was leaked under my watch
and
i don't know how many people had access
to these emails but these are i believe
senior executives who look through comb
through these emails
it doesn't take me long to call role to
say uh let's come in here because we had
somebody who leaked this imprint does
roger goodell care that somebody leaked
this information i think he has to
you know any leader is going to worry
about loose lip syncing ships he hasn't
said anything publicly yeah i think
that's what we need all we've had is a
statement from their pr guys saying we
didn't leak it now
this is going to have to be addressed
this is going to have to be addressed
because at some point he's got to
address what's coming out of washington
right and
yes
i think we need statements here beyond
you know gruden screwed up
so
that's why i use this word sacrifice and
i don't mean to be dramatic with it i
just don't get this there's more to this
story
and
be careful what you wish for i guess to
whoever's leaking it
but here's a question dan
answer me this i know you bet we've
asked questions
what if
emails surface
from an owner oh i know
making
misogynistic racist comments are we
firing the owner
are we are we firing the owner
because we just fired britain
well i think that that's what's involved
here i think you have why wouldn't there
be correspondence between owners you
know jerry jones and dan snyder are best
friends uh i think that there was a coup
that they were trying to get rid of
roger goodell a couple of years ago do i
think that they corresponded in email
perhaps to say things about roger
goodell
i i mean it almost feels like roger
goodell's protecting the owners from the
owners yeah listen for people who don't
know and i think everyone knows by now
roger goodell is paid and hired by the
owners this idea of this players
commissioner and i know we have some of
that with the nba but
no he's sir he's he they're his
constituents he's there to serve them
and he's done a great job on the
business business is booming it's better
than ever right now the nfl
has multi-year deals with both with
labor and with media
they're set
so for whatever reason they wanted these
emails out about gruden and they were
sent to the washington club with bruce
allen that's what's so weird here we
don't see responses back from alan we
don't see anything else from washington
going that way to gruden
a lot lot to ask but legally
yeah
can anybody
file anything that brings out these
emails that that makes them public
yeah it's funny because we got something
going on in
st louis litigation
where they filed discovery requests for
that this
is not a lawsuit that's the difference
you know this is a investigation which
is done by a washington dc law firm
which seems to be taken over
surreptitiously i think by the league
so that seems hardly independent and
also did john gruden have his agent
present when he decided to step down and
is there a payoff here
did he get paid uh for the rest of this
like i don't know it just seems like
mark davis shows up and says john you
got to step down you you know you can't
be a distraction and then what
i don't think for a minute
he's leaving behind he's leaving with
zero okay so i think
there have been a lot of negotiations
which may still be ongoing
say he has pick a number 50 60 million
left on that deal
believe you me dan he's not walking away
with zero
so listen he could be a thorn in the nfl
side here
he could be he says well here's what i
got back
or here's what i know
and i think he's being paid off as part
of a settlement and part of it's going
to be an nda
no disparaging comments nothing else
coming out of this he's not getting 50
60 million believe me but he's not
walking away with nothing so it's some
number where his agent i think it's
still bob lamont who i dealt with for
years there's this whole andy reed tree
includes gruden i would mike holmgren
trees sorry that includes reed and
gruden
where all these coaches have bob lamont
and lawyers working for them
does this get worse in the coming weeks
the nfl hopes not i mean hopes that this
is the end but
listen
i think you i think me i think everyone
in national media would like to know
more
obviously fans and the public
but
this is i
i guess my i talk about sacrifice did
the nfl whoever leaked this really think
we'd sort of brush it off and say let's
go on to the next topic i think the nfl
thinks that i think they're hoping that
yeah i think they're not gonna
i think we
transparency breeds trust
i get emails from people like they're
like the mafia well
the mafia has secrets when you have
secrets you're gonna get those kind of
comments
great to touch base with you keep
stirring it up on twitter andrew thanks
for joining us as always
always a pleasure dan talk soon that's
andrew brandt sports illustrated
columnist and host of businesses sports
podcast a former packers executive and
director of villanova sports law and
business program